why do you think you are so good
what is it that about you what is it
about your experience what is it about
your game
uh I I don't know I I think
um you need to be absolutely confident
and I think it's it's always better to
be overly confident than pessimistic
because I I realize sometimes after
games that you know
uh I was actually way too confident here
I was way too optimistic but if you're
not optimistic if you're not looking for
your chances You're Gonna Miss
You're Gonna Miss opportunities
uh
and um
you know
um
I mean I I think there are there are
plenty of uh players in history who have
been you know immensely talented but
there's uh they're they're just too
pessimistic they see too many
uh dangers that are not there and so on
so that they cannot
performance they see dangers that are
not there yeah so therefore they don't
play at the highest level yeah no it's
it's just uh it's amazing
I I realized from time time to time you
know people who are
not not
particularly strong players but but
still
uh they're very good players but they
could be one of one of the best if they
just you know had had more confidence
and and when I'm you know I'm analyzing
with them when I'm looking at chess I
realize you know
they're
you know they know everything about the
game but nevertheless they kind of play
there's a missing thing yeah yeah it's
like a Winner's Edge yeah you know you
need to have that you you need to have
that edge you need to have that
confidence you need to have that you
know absolute belief uh that you're
you're the best and you'll win every
time I've always been competitive and uh
I I never liked losing I never thought
that losing is a natural part of the
game and I think that's that's the way
it has to be if you want want to be able
and if it's a very tough opponent yeah
um
and you say the word checkmate
well I I won't actually say the word
Checkmate but when my you know that you
say check and yeah and they they all
realize you know you can see it in their
face yeah that's uh
um that's a good feeling obviously but
but I mean for me what's even more
satisfying is is the battle uh leading
up to the point where you you're gaining
an advantage you're uh the route to the
event yes and your opponents is uh
spending a lot of time making faces uh
and you know you know that's that you
got him you know they're struggling yeah
and uh and I mean I mean that's in a way
the most satisfying more than than the
end which is often you know a matter of
uh wrapping up yeah that's over yeah